fosho joe belladonna to the falafel say
i am currently in paris for paris games
week and today i'm going to be talking
all about my highlights of sony's press
conference but more than just a
highlight i did also get some
behind-the-scenes looks at wild dreams
and gravity rush to and a whole bunch of
PlayStation VR so I can elaborate a
little on those as well I should also
mention that i'm currently in the hotel
bathroom because the lighting in these
french hotels is all moody and atrocious
first things first i think this is a
really really good press conference it
wasn't just shoot out after sugar after
sugar even though they started with call
of duty which i'm pretty sure only 13
year old boys really like when they do
that but the rest of the conference was
tons of variety and a lot of really
really interesting games there was an
eerie star wars battlefront trailer
which is just the sexiest thing that
I've ever seen it really tell us much
was largely cinematic but they do a
great job of those cinematics and oh my
god the sound the star wars battlefront
is just amazing and then they should
have some interesting titles including
boundless I'm not exactly sure what that
is but it kind of looks like minecraft
accept it definitely carries itself it
has its own vibe and also avicii vector
which is a weirdly I think that is
basically like a child of Eden but more
EDM then we saw a little bit more of
them at sky nothing particularly new
which I mean it's going to be really
hard to make a trailer for no man's sky
because
you don't know what you're ever going to
find but it's nice to be coming out in
June 2016 I was originally supposed to
be coming out this year i think but
they've obviously pushed it back I'm not
gonna lie I am getting a little bit
worried about no man's sky I feel like
and may be crucified being critical of
it because people love it so much but
I'm starting to wonder if the game is
actually just good in theory and not
good in practice the theory behind the
whole freaking 19 billion planets or
whatever it is procedurally generated
universe is incredible that's amazing
that we can do that with a game but I'm
starting to doubt that it's actually
going to be any fun to play of all of
the stuff that we've seen a lot of it's
been very similar and you know I
actually don't have any interest in
playing it beyond the concept behind it
please don't hate me hangman I never saw
some more horizon zero dawn which was
the one thing that I really wanted to
see more of going into that conference I
think that game looks awesome the
trailer showed a little bit more of the
gameplay which is similar to stuff we've
seen in the past but I don't really had
a lot of property vibes from it and the
game world looks beautiful the concept
is really really interesting it's set in
a future where humans have seemingly
been near extinct and some kind of
organic machines have taken over but the
gameplay also looks really really smooth
with all the sliding and rolling and the
different amounts of uses for the bone
in a combat
since you can lay traps you can sink
broke arrows into the organic machines
that you were trying to take down and
again we don't know too much but I do
really like everything and I've seen it
and I liked how fluid the motion looked
in this so I'm just getting more and
more excited about finding out what
about it after that was dreams which is
so hard to talk about a beautiful quote
from the behind closed doors sessions
was one of dev said we don't know what
rooms is and I don't think they will
know exactly what rings is until the
community decides what it is because you
can do anything in dreams but a better
way to describe dreams is that it's a
social media but for sharing crazy like
LSD fueled content so you'll follow your
favorite creators like you would follow
someone in Instagram you might follow
different people for different reasons
one person because they make Google
short films and other because they make
high action shooting games another
because they make cool sculptures of
things as far as I can tell and from
what I have seen of people creating
stuff in front of me it's almost
limitless and it's it's just such a
shame that it's really hard to explain
without automatically selling it short I
think it's going to be really great that
they showed out Robinson the journey
which is a new PlayStation VR game with
a terrible name what we saw was a kind
of first-person be our experience in
dinosaurs using CryEngine which means
that it looks amazing but it seemed kind
of like towards the end of the trailer
the play I was going to be taken out of
it so I'm wondering if it's like a time
travel thing either way if the VIP
experience is going to look anything
like it did in that trailer it's going
to be absolutely incredible and then
there was until
in the VR game I don't know that if it
is when I saw there was until dawn PR I
was like yes and my story was like a
roller coaster and it was I'm
disappointed but I did play that today
it's not particularly scary and nothing
about it makes me think of until dawn at
all it's kind of like an arcade game
what I played today though I'm sure it's
a really early demo wasn't particularly
interesting I'm Alicia number of wild
which I'm super interested in wild
basically lets you go from a child to an
adult as a shaman who can control
various animals now beyond the ability
to kind of RPG style yes big hold of
animals that you control I'm not sure if
it's going to be narrative driven and I
find that a little bit disappointing
because in the behind closed door
session they just kept telling us we
want the player to be able to choose the
story in full of book they're Jews like
well does that mean that there's going
to be some kind of interesting narrative
although I does that mean I'm just going
to be running around and trying to claim
animals but again this is something that
I think looks gorgeous the concept is
definitely interesting and I look
forward to finding our ball and then it
ended on a debit cage game Detroit
Detroit takes a clone and follows
journey into becoming human presumably
have no idea what kind of game it is
what genre is going to be or anything
but i can assume it's going to play like
heavy rain beyond two souls it's going
to be David catching another interesting
concept but probably an overly cinematic
trailer that means that we don't really
learn much about it some of those were
my highlights from Playstations Paris
games week conference if you guys want
to let me know what you think as well
and stay tuned to my channel I'll have
tons more Paris games week content
coming
over the next couple of weeks I'm ilona
thank you guys for watching I'll see you
next time